oh my goodness you guys I am so hyped
now many of you know that I am a huge
Star Wars fan and I also tend to claim
that I'm a Jedi in training but aside
from that I freaking love collecting
things and this is where my new friends
at kryptoys came in and said hey Justine
we think that we've got something that
you might like and they were so right
they just launched this entire line of
Star Wars digital collectible toys there
are 15 various versions of Luke
Skywalker Princess Leia and Darth Vader
that you can collect each character has
five different Rarities that spanned
from common rare legendary Grail and
Ultra Grail they are limited edition so
they will sell out and as you'll see on
this pack there's a little seal right
here and that signifies that this is a
first edition and won't ever be made
again